recently there is a report that has come
out according to laura shin with her new
book that they have identified who they
believe is part of the 11 billion hack
of ether back from the dao now most
people know this story that
ethereum was chugging along there was a
dow that dow was hacked and in order to
actually try to silence or mitigate that
risk what ethereum did is they forked
and they created ethereum of what you
know today an ethereum classic theorem
classic being the old chain ethereum
being the new chain but now lorishan her
book and a number of her sources they
claim to have identified one of the
people behind that hack it's an
australian
an austrian programmer and a former
founder of a crypto
company i guess
now
let's see
a lot of details to go through
the dow was basically just a
decentralized venture fund right it was
139 million dollars in ether at the time
of its crowd sale in 2016
and it was the most successful crowd
sale to date at that point
weeks later the hacker siphoned 31
percent of the east out of the dow which
was 3.64 million total or about five
percent of all east that was outstanding
at the time
and they put it into a new down
now
there's a guy toby hoynish 36 year old
programmer who grew up in austria was
living in singapore at the time of the
hack who has reportedly been identified
as the hacker now he denies this
and
laura shin i guess reached out to him
after he denied it and tried to get more
information from him he stopped
responding etc so we've got a chart here
that shows uh kind of a timeline of
events and what you can see is the dow
sale starts in you know
april may of 2016. the crowd sale ends
at the end of may there's the dow hack
and then you get the hard fork in july
and then from there you get ethereum
classic and you get eth now the reason
why this is interesting is obviously the
value of a ether has continued to go up
incredibly high and so what was stolen
today would be worth about 11 billion
the time was not worth 11 billion
dollars
second
is that from what we can tell
there has been no
court case
nobody has been proven to do this
there's no admittance of guilt or
anything
what we have is a journalist who is
pointing and saying you did it
they have sources they have some
evidence in terms of being able to use
some of the uh analytics tools chain
analysis etc
and so they believe that this is the
person who did it
but there is no
guarantee of it and so this to me is one
of those like slippery slopes right is
obviously we want journalists to be
doing the work in order to
help break open cases like this to do
journalism right et cetera at the same
time though is this guy let's say let's
give him the benefit of the doubt
presume that he did not do it he said he
didn't do it so let's just say for
example in a hypothetical situation that
he did not do it
imagine having your name drug through
the mainstream media
as being the hacker of 11 billion
dollars
and not having the 11 billion dollars
not having done it and having no way to
clear your name right in the sense of uh
uh in in the mainstream press
pretty crazy stuff and so i think that
this is one of those situations where
like we don't want to discourage
journalists from doing their job uh the
evidence again
uh from what i've read already this
morning seems to be uh fairly compelling
but at the same time there's this
balance between like people should be
innocent until proven guilty and when we
put their names out into the public
arena
it creates a scenario where i think
folks say
damn in the court of public opinion that
person's guilty maybe maybe not i don't
know but
will we ever actually get you know if he
if he didn't do it will we ever get that
known in public as much as it's known
that you know he's accused of doing it
yeah that that sucks right because if he
didn't do it one he doesn't have the
money so
and two his name was basically would
that be okay if he didn't have the money
no but i mean if he didn't look i'm not
a i'm not a judge jury i
i know a little bit about this case from
articles and online but i haven't seen
both facts laid out in their arguments
together but look if he if he did it
he's got 11 billion dollars
i wouldn't be showing up in court 511
billion dollars um but yeah look his
name got dragged through the mud right
and i hope that this is figured out i
think it's interesting that he basically
stole five percent of all eath
outstanding at the time ethereum was
around twenty dollars obviously now it
sits around four thousand dollars so
it's a very big increase in price
um but yeah look he moved it around it
seems to be a lot of evidence point to
that he did it obviously he's saying he
did not do it um and i guess the courts
will decide if this ever goes that
direction
so
i think that a huge piece of this is um
the public opinion right which we talked
about
two though is a lot of people
that now are showing up to the
cryptocurrency industry uh they don't
know about this hard fork that actually
created ethereum classic and ethereum
it's one of the reasons why a lot of
bitcoiners look at the ethereum um
uh
ecosystem and they have questions right
or or they're less bullish on it uh than
maybe they were before and the whole
idea was uh this was some uh kind of uh
centralized decision making that
occurred here to actually go ahead
create the hard fork uh uh to to
essentially try to roll back the chain
so that you could mitigate this theft
and so the thought process is like are
they just gonna play favorites over when
to do this and when not right if all of
a sudden john stole one eath from me uh
why don't they roll back the chain or
why don't they go ahead and and create a
hard fork so i get my one eat back right
oh is it because it's not enough money
is it because the community was involved
like there's a bunch of stuff in there
uh that ends up being uh very very
different than i think the way that the
bitcoin community approaches it now with
that said that doesn't mean necessarily
uh that the bitcoin community is right
but it's important to understand why now
i have my own personal views and i tend
to think that uh the
kind of variable decision making around
uh when to roll back or when to uh hard
fork uh is probably not great for the
long-term sustainability of the chain
ultimately if you have an immutable
ledger you want it to be immutable you
want it to uh not be at the whim of a
group of people who can say hey we don't
like a situation that happened let's
make a difference here uh we saw in the
past other people have suggested that we
could do that with bitcoin and they very
quickly uh the community kind of rose up
and said no absolutely not that's not
what we do here um and so i think that
there's uh some uniqueness to the
situation not just uh the headlines
which are you know there's money stolen
and it's grown to be a lot of money but
also there was
an important part of history around uh
ethereum blockchains themselves hard
forks how to deal with uh nefarious
actors uh what constitutes
people to step in and try to advocate
for some sort of change to the technical
nature of uh of the blockchain what
would not constitute that etc so there's
a lot of things you can learn so uh if
you want um you should go read the
articles you should go read the book i
think that a lot of folks will uh will
learn quite a bit from from that
situation